why has it always seemed to be the
losing side I think it's the losing side
in the world of intellectuals and
perhaps in the media too because
instincts are hard to discuss and even
harder to defend if you're in the
business of repudiating things throwing
things away declaring your emancipation
from your past you get an audience
pretty quickly and you easily find
things to say but if you're in the
business of trying to defend
what is your basic sense of belonging in
this world words quickly run out but
nevertheless when it comes to voting or
making decisions for the family and
whatever the Instinct prevails and this
is why in the intellectual world the
left is always in the ascendant whereas
in the real world which I occasionally
Glimpse and the right is always the
solid basis on which people stand